yeah welcome to this video we are going
to play another of that 25-minute games
25 minute 10 second increment the
official feeder rapid time control you
are playing Elemeno of zone or something
I cannot see 15 million rating is 1600
this is what what we want to compare it
with okay um yeah this laughs let's play
the mainland and see what is doing is
taking this yeah I recently had a brief
look at that line at some it's a
sideline and it's not bad it's a good
line if you want want a simple way to
play against that that main line Slav a4
is far more complicated okay it's
already taking a bit of time here
surprisingly after a for pretty much
before it's the only move why is he
trying something else huh there's not
much that you can try here actually
Bishop d7 try to it no it's going to be
up g fo okay so why can I not just take
the pawn I think I can and I will I mean
I have much more time on my hands with
that time control but there's no
particular reason not to take it yeah in
there in the early days of saturating
pool you will always have those
mismatches and this is also a bit of a
mismatch but there's no no way around
that you have to start with start with
playing and at the time will come pretty
soon that oh this is going to be more
balanced okay so i got that pawn on beef
five so we've got equal material now I
can just take si form an alternative
idea would be queen a for attending yeah
those discoveries after Queen a for you
will probably play Knight B to D seven
and then I have 95 maybe but I wonder if
really this is a situation where I can
yeah maybe I think I think this is this
is a good move anyway it also prevents
Bishop before check which is not super
dangerous or anything but it's not bad
to have prevented that
yeah what is the idea that bd7 looks
like almost the only move here I can
also just takes e4 of course oh wow that
is surprising I'm probably not very good
95 this looks very annoying 95 okay if I
go 95 is there something that you can do
you can check your night Bishop before
check
o 95 I wonder that couple of funny lines
here I can I can absolutely cannot take
Adam I have 96 on 97 I mean they're both
should win 95 picture before checker I
was kind of irritating but i know i can
i can actually just go back 93 and then
the pin on c6 is completely winning okay
so then this is a good move i will first
i was thinking after Bishop before check
I have to play Bishop t2 which now okay
he can take King takes and I'm sort of
in the middle of the King I don't know
it looks it looked a bit more
complicated than I would like it to be
and after Bishop before check but I just
have 93 and then the pin on along a 48
is some is completely deadly
Jeff don't see morally if he goes let's
say rook c8 for example covering the the
night and I just take the night and play
now Jack's 87 yeah 93 s is the key move
we should be towards probably also good
but it's that that's it's totally
unnecessary complicated and it's not
entirely clear maybe after Bishop T to
take stakes even prove she can only five
but this is a very clear thing now I see
six is some attacked twice by the Queen
on the diagonal and the night only five
NTS normal really to parry that
Jeff ok
yeah he loses you will lose the night
now yeah whenever you go b5 in phnom
penh in now and especially in Queens
gambit structures be five in combination
with the Bishop Bishop out to g4 to f5
whenever that happens the light squares
are always going to be M going to be
weak and that is a typical case of that
I hear you led to the loss of a piece
you know yeah Knight takes is good Queen
takes also good I think Bishop e3 and
seem sensible activating the bishop
attacking the Roca yeah jack is even
wins another exchange sorry so how to
continue from here oh okay it's me it's
just a row calm but that's evidence go
f3 and push the bishop back and yeah
maybe if for on Bishop c5 is also and
then 95 maybe
yeah this is ok if he really wants to go
Queen to f4 i still have bishop see one
back ok so here is going to try to play
night to be six but I've queen is I've
got Queen a sixer snow need to worry
here
he also played relatively quickly it's
often difficult to adjust to a new time
control especially if you never have
played it before in any kind of
competition 2510 is also new for me but
he's he struggles a little bit him and
place her attack too quickly which costs
huge material yeah I kept taking wow
plan designs yeah there's there's some
some glitch there with that um why
exactly i think i actually have the file
opener okay anyway this was the end of
the game let's do a recap thereof that
off that game see what went wrong yeah
we had a Slav and accepted III the most
common move is a four to prevent this b5
idea altogether and only later regain
the porn with III or 95 those are the
two most common ways to regain the point
after you three black plays b5 he got
that one right and then a four is played
yeah and now black essentially only has
one move he has to go B form and yeah
this is gaining a bit of time on the on
the night night now can go back to be
one or 2a to it actually can lead to the
same position I probably would have
played that one and then we get
something like that this kind of this
kind of structure like this um yeah
black is developing like this yeah this
kind of thing and wide we'll go like
here night over to be three and this is
probably about equal but it's relatively
easy to play and you basically only have
this kind of thing to worry about i mean
various strong word even but it's the
only thing to expect really everything
else here is bad
and this is one case of a bad move
Bishop g4 he gives away b5 and yeah he
really has no other move then before he
goes a six and I can really grab that
there are some cases where black can
give up an exchange like that but this
is not one of them here there is no
compensation so no other move freedom if
you try to protect b5 you have to face
this idea and again I'm threatening to
take here and here and also on b5 and
queen of three the idea that goes like
this I have Bishop c4 cute intermediate
move so whatever black does he really
should go before yeah him and things got
very very problematic after Queen a for
the engine already gives plus to point
something and seems to be yeah almost it
seems to be winning this is the best
best tribe then I would have played this
move and yeah this is also hampering
black quite a bit what you would like to
do is to move this Bishop somehow but
where before see 5d6 it's all guarded
Bishop e7 runs into 96 and this is very
awkward to go in here check and that
yeah it's a complete disaster yeah but
still he had to go NAB bd7 and after
that wyd wins huge chunks of material um
if he takes I wasn't actually totally
sure what to do this looks interesting
you know well let's assume here and just
take this it's also possibility that's
not bad I think I would have gone for
96 computer gives plus for something in
both cases yeah okay he went with the
check and now it's simple to just
retreat Bishop b2 check and here this is
at least unnecessarily complicated maybe
97's bet is good but it's totally
unnecessary to check because this
retreat just wins this piece check and
down yeah the rest is check rest is very
easy and yeah don't really need doesn't
need any commentary yeah okay as I
mentioned in the in the first video with
that then the new rating pool we have
some mismatches at the beginning but
this will even will be evened out
relatively quickly okay thanks for
watching my